minister thank you for talking to us
um one of the things that i know a lot
of people in this country are going to
be curious about you know we
we've just heard that we are facing
unprecedented energy bills in this
country for domestic customers you know
what is there that qatar can do to help
the uk right now
well first thank you for hosting me on
your channel it's a pleasure to be in
the uk
you see if you look at the energy
crisis and what's happening around the
world this started really
many months or even years i'd say before
the ukraine crisis yeah so really before
russia
yeah definitely before that i mean if
you look at what happened with the
transition and the discussion of the
transition a lot of companies in the oil
and gas sector did not invest in oil and
gas especially in the gas sector so that
was much needed but
if you look from 2015 until now
year on year there has been a 20
reduction in capital expenditure and
that was really amplified when you had
the carved uh issue with the revenues
coming down
in all oil and gas companies and really
stagnation if you will in the entire
world movement
uh with the covet and what was going on
uh what happened is
really that came down to about 35
percent reduction in capital expenditure
so
so the supply that you needed for energy
after the covet was over and people
started there you know the economy
started to churn
back again uh wasn't available and you
know with oil and gas projects
even you know if you decide today you
want to have an nng plant built in a
country with the wells and drilling and
everything that
that needs to
take place to have it produced for the
customer it's about seven to ten years
so so there's a lag it will it will it
will
eventually be corrected by more
investment
in the energy sector
and i think
countries are realizing and then of
course the ukraine issue amplified that
tremendously with the energy security
issues and the lack of supply that's
available but now you'll see the the
countries are have been i think changing
their strategy where they're saying we
need the transition but we need
additional supply from everybody in the
oil and gas industry and around the
world so that we have ample supplies
that would bring the prices down and
prices are higher it's
you know it's a sheer supply demand
issue but what you're saying is that
actually you know this goes way back
before
russia ukraine
it's because what because we we weren't
encouraging enough
investment in oil and gas exploration is
that is that the issues that go back is
it a deeper issue than you know just
something that's happened a few months
ago uh i think it's it's definitely a
deeper issue and it was it was there uh
for more than five years where there was
a buildup to to
countries and and
really legislators around the world
pushing for the transition in a in a
very hard way
uh thinking you mean that zero you mean
zero and going to renewables and and
really doing away with fossil fuel and
uh demonizing oil and gas companies that
they are the bad guys if you will and by
that you don't have enough investment in
the in the oil and gas sector so that
that in turn had
you know when the legislators put that
in place and put pressure on the
companies banks went into the same they
wanted to only fund green and so on and
i think you can you can actually strike
a balance between
having you know energy sector that can
be responsible and do
uh the right things with with uh you
know technologies available for carbon
capture sequestration and so on so
coupled with that i think we have a a
very good solution where you have
uh gas available while you're also
investing in renewables like solar wind
and so on we absolutely need to change
our behavior and make sure that the
energy transition is on track but i
think you need to to do both and we
think as qatar that gas is definitely
part of the solution for your base load
requirement and then energy because the
wind does not blow all the time and the
sun does not shine all the time but you
know so a lot of people would say what
we're going through now is you know
west the west is kind of a victim of
circumstances
some would say it is
you know it's brought this upon itself
which of those is true i think it's a as
i said it's it's something that that is
fundamental that was done to change the
supply
structure in the energy sector as a
whole
and then
coupled with with what was amplified by
the ukraine issue right okay so it's a
little bit of both but but the ukraine
issue really
um put in the forefront energy security
as a different issue that we need or
countries need to deal with uh you know
as an example germany and their their
turnaround to really wanting to have
full
diversity if you will and now going from
not having lng terminals to building
maybe five in the very near future and
that circumstances have changed and i
think companies and countries
are changing but i think we're all
realizing and i think countries and
i think legislators all around the world
you need energy transition we need to do
something about climate change we need
to be more responsible in fossil fuel
development
but we need fossil fuels and we need
them for a very long time and gas
especially is going to be part of the
base load that you'll need for many
years to come and what part
can qatar play in that
how much can you help now
given that
prices are incredibly high for consumers
right now we need more gas especially
this winter
how can you help you see we've taken a
decision a few years back maybe in 2017
we decided that we're going to increase
our gas development
our lng production currently stands at
77 million tons we decided that we're
going to take it to 126 million tons and
we embarked on that project and that
project is being constructed today what
we did also is we secured additional
capacity that we are we own now and
montoya and france were receiving
facilities for our rng and zebra
terminal where there was a process that
we won
here and i mean we're in the uk so let's
talk about the uk a little bit we have a
south hook terminal in in wales where we
have a capacity of 16
and
a half
15.6 or 60 million tons per annum of lng
that we can bring into the
uk if we bring that entire capacity it's
about 20 of your requirement uh on an
annual basis we also
actually bought capacity in isle of
green in the west of of
the uk for seven and a half uh
7.2 million tons per annum for 30 years
or uh you know so so we're really
investing into
into the uk uh heavily to make sure that
you have ample supplies in the future in
addition to that we've applied and we
are going to be building an expansion of
south going from 60 million tons to
about 20 million tons uh in the next few
years which is
again hundreds of millions of
investments so having these
you know inlets if you will for gas or
receiving facilities uk already is the
biggest
holder of capacity
capacity in europe and and by doing that
we're we're only making you bigger as a
capacity holder if you will and we we
look to supply the uk
with lng for a very long time us and
others but this is all quite stuff that
understandably takes quite a long time
to to build and to get up and running
is it just pragmatically quite difficult
to suddenly turn the taps on it does it
work like that it doesn't and that's why
you see when we decided in 2017 we're
going to have this production
increase we're going to have it online
by 2025. so it takes time to build but
we took the decision before anybody was
even thinking about this and and so we
had the foresight i think in in in
making in in believing that we
there is going to be a supply shortage
anybody
i mean could tell you it could be 2025
or 2030 but we took the decision we
invested in addition to volumes that
we're going to bring in from qatar we
also have a project in the
u.s which has 16 million tons
per annum of
supply capability that will come online
actually ahead of qatar in 2024 that is
also destined for europe and how does it
feel having
you know had a good few years where the
message you were getting from europe was
actually you need to cut back on fossil
fuels
and now suddenly everyone here wants to
talk to you and they want they want you
to be pumping more gas there
how does that feel to go from one
extreme to the other i think i think
everybody had hopes uh with good
intention to to to to
and believe that they can go into a
transition in a much uh more expedited
way and i think what uh
in reality what they saw is year on year
they can't increase that capacity of
wind solar and renewables in the pace
that they thought they could and i think
with with good intentions that was the
objective but i think they couldn't
achieve it and it's difficult to achieve
exactly what they thought they could
achieve technology improvement is going
to have us do much more i mean hydrogen
is is in its infancy but we need to
learn much more and hydrogen is also
going to be helping we need all kinds of
energy sources to pitch in if you will
for us to grow as a humanity but but gas
is definitely a big part of the solution
and as i said earlier i mean
wind does not blow all the time
sun does not shine all the time
definitely here in the uk it's not gonna
shine all the time and qatar 365 days it
would shine so every everywhere is
different and everybody is unique but i
think all of us collectively working
together with gas as part of the
solution i think is the solution for the
long term and gas and you know again
you're being quite diplomatic but i know
that you know there are people certainly
within the oil and gas community who
feel frustrated that
there were quite strong messages also
the cost of capital kind of has been has
been going up because of this
movement to ensure that we get to net
zeros sooner
so do you feel
somewhat frustrated about having
been sent mixed messages one thing one
year the other the other day
actually maybe you think i am being
diplomatic but actually i'm not i mean
that's my view
but if you talk about
the net zero part of it okay that's
where i think
a lot of people were were saying
uh you know i'm not a native english
speaker but when you say i will achieve
net zero it means you have a
plan
a budget and you will achieve it the
majority of the countries that have
announced net zero actually aspire to
you know have a plan to hopefully
achieve but will means you have a plan
and you have a budget and you know how
you're getting there if you ask the
majority of the countries they will tell
you we will get to a certain percentage
of that by 2040 and then technology
improvement hopefully will get us
to net zero by 2050 which means that
they are
just saying what is right or politically
right to say but they actually don't
have a plan um
i mean how does that
how does that kind of
strike you as someone who's trying to
think in the very long term to me we
were we were absolutely convinced you
can't achieve
the transition
without fossil fuels
and the best fossil fuel available to
mankind is gas and that's the cleanest
and if you couple it with using
carbon capture and sequestration using
the best technology available for your
emissions
and you couple it with having the
shipping
element to being the cleanest shipping
available where we're fueling our new
ships purely on lng there is no liquid
fuel or
any any hydrocarbon that's that's the
heavier hydrocarbons that they use today
and ensuring that we use we also use
part of of the power that's used for our
lng it uses uh solar in our back in
qatar in addition to that we're helping
humanity overall and people that buy our
gas to get rid of coal
and liquid fuels so in our
you know the way i see it is the gas is
the solution and it's the solution if
you do it in the right way that you're
cleaning up that value chain as much as
you can technically and what technology
provides today in addition to helping
others
get off the more polluting
areas so i think we're doing a great
service by having more gas us and others
by having more gas available to
humanity as a whole to get rid of of the
less of the more polluting uh fossil
fuels if you will
final thing on on on energy
do you have a particular message
you know to to households in the uk
who are looking at their gas bills and
just wondering
how has it got to this why are they so
expensive
how do we find ourselves in a new energy
crisis
and why are we
the victims to some extent
you see the the issue is you're in a
global market
whether it's uk europe qatar anywhere
you go it's the same market and people
you know look at oil and gas as
substitutes in some areas and so on but
but overall
everybody whether it's in the uk it's in
in the u.s it's in qatar they're paying
roughly the same thing as just logistics
are different so if you look at
continental europe today the gas the
spot price gas is much higher than uk
okay and the reason for that is you have
a lot of inlets for gas and you have an
interconnect and you have pipelines
coming from norway and so on so you have
your lng coming to we have our lng our
and others lng that come to you we're
happy to serve this market but at the
end it's because you have all that gas
that's available if you look at europe
and why it's higher they don't have
enough terminals that are built
you go to spain uh in the south they
have
ample capacity with spare capacity but
but spain is sort of an island in the
gas business because there isn't enough
interconnect but the irony is it's not
benefiting households here because
our futures prices are still very high i
understand so households are still
frustrated because they see
all your gas coming in they see the day
ahead price is very low
but it doesn't directly benefit them
yeah i think i think you see we go back
to to promoting more investment
in in
gas
worldwide and our companies i think the
uk has taken you know very courageous
moves if you will in in opening up gas
blocks to have more indigenous gas come
in
to support the uk
they're working on hydrogen they're
working on renewables you have wind you
have so you're in a better shape than a
lot of other
countries in my view but i think this
will take time with investment going
into i think oil and gas companies are
now investing in gas it will take time
but with more investments and supporting
investments more supporting banks to to
to help gas producers to to
invest that will eventually bring the
price down because you'll have more
supply unfortunately it's a little bit
painful because it will take time
amplified by the ukraine issue
right but you're ready to help
we're absolutely ready i mean the uk is
a very important country for us in
europe and we will definitely
uh do our best to help
final question i have to ask you because
it's the world cup coming up a lot of
people looking at qatar you know also
reading stories about how
open you're going to be to be welcoming
all sorts of people you know different
sexualities different cultural
backgrounds
how open is this world cup going to be
qatar is is a country that has
300 people living in it the the qatari
native qataris are about 300 000
we have
you know nationality more than 150
nationalities that work with us
they work in harmony with
all of us and qatar to develop our
country in different sectors whether
it's oil and gas or other sectors it's
the safest country in the world by by
as far as actual safety of people
walking around
and this is well known uh it's it's a
welcoming culture where we welcome
everybody from all religions all walks
of life and everybody's welcome uh
no matter where they're coming from what
their allegiance is how what they their
preferences are they're all welcome to
qatar and they can come and enjoy the
world cup and also learn about our
culture and learn about how
what our traditions are what's our
religion and so on but everybody is
welcome and we don't we don't have any
uh kind of discrimination against
anybody everybody is welcome to kata
okay well we are all very looking
looking forward to that a lot and and i
i i
wish uh england all the best yeah
fingers crossed minister thank you so
much thank you